la lumière au bout du tunnel c'est ce
que serena williams a déclaré quand on
lui a demandé ce qui l'a motivé à
continuer après sa victoire lundi à
toronto cette lumière si la liberté que
séverine elle espère trouver après sa
longue carrière professionnelle amorcé
en 1995 à québec où elle a joué son
premier tournoi à 14 ans 73 championnat
en simple dont 23 titres du grand chelem
c'est une araignée mais selon plusieurs
la plus grande championne de l'histoire
du tennis elle a aussi gagné l'or
olympique enceinte lalonde et en double
avec sa soeur venus à signer pékin et
londres les deux soeurs sont invaincus
en équipe lors des finales du grand
chelem elle en longue annie 14 ensemble
mais les soeurs williams ont laissé leur
marque ailleurs que sur le terrain
[Musique]
elles ont souvent dénoncé le racisme
dont elle était la cible est un incident
survenu en 2001 à indian wells ou si
rina et son père avaient été
copieusement hué les avait amenés à
boycotter le tournoi pendant une dizaine
d'années syrie n'a pas hésité non plus à
parler de sa situation de mer et
d'athlètes dans le texte du vogue elle
souligne que si elle avait été un homme
elle aurait pu continuer à jouer et
gagner des championnats aussi longtemps
que tom brady ce qu'elle n'a pu faire
comme femme puisqu'elle s'est arrêté
pour donner naissance à sa fille olympia
a aussi une influence sur ses collègues
du circuit de tennis professionnel
féminin bien cadré squale est l'occasion
de l'affronter deux fois l'été 2010 9
quand la canadienne s'est imposé sur la
scène internationale avec ses victoires
à toronto houston toutes deux en finale
contre civile des moments émouvants
deux fois montréal pour les
internationaux du canada il n'a jamais
gagné ici s'incline en finale contre
martina hingis en 2001 et contre sa
soeur venus lors de la demi-finale en
2014 premier volet a dit merci à ma mère
elle a quand même trouvé le moyen de
gagner partisans en s'adressant à la
foule en français et avant d'avoir juste
l'étiquette de jouer au tennis mais elle
est suivie n'auraient rien elle est
allée bien au-delà
du tennis et même du monde ici pas
serena williams pourrait raccrocher sa
raquette à new york le mois prochain
elle tentera alors de mettre la main sur
un quatrième titre du grand chelem sur
le terrain où il avait gagné son premier
en 1999 jean saint-onge radio canada
montréal